- I think we are finally
ready to get started.
First off, thanks everyone for
joining this session today.
I know you guys got a lot
of choices to pick from,
so we're really happy
for you to join us here
to talk about sustainability.
So before we dive right
in, wanted to just get
a quick kind of poll
on the audience.
Who here works in sustainability?
Does anyone work in sustainability?
Touch the sustainability data.
Okay, we got a few.
How about operations, operations?
We got some software
development engineers in here.
Okay, got a couple of those
How about FinOps?
Okay. Also this blinding light.
So I see about two hands out there.
Okay, all right, great, well,
hopefully this talk will kind
of touch on all of those dimensions
and have something a
little bit interesting
for our builders out there,
our FinOps, our operations,
and, of course, hopefully you
all walk away here wanting
to get more into sustainability
or at least thinking more about it.
Last question before we
kind of dive right in,
who knows what the customer
carbon footprint tool is?
Ooh, we got, all right, three, all right.
By the end of this talk, you will all know
what the customer carbon
footprint tool is,
and hopefully you will all
go there and check it out
and see what it is and what
information and can provide you.
All right, let's jump here.
All right, so just to recap,
you are in session 332.
In this session,
I'm joined by some colleagues in Adobe
and Salesforce to talk about
how they're enabling their
sustainability initiatives
using the customer carbon footprint tool.
My name is Alexis Bateman.
I am at AWS and I lead our
sustainability tech team.
We are en we enable all
of our sustainability objectives at AWS,
whether that be on our net
zero carbon objectives,
our water positive, our
renewable energy goals.
We are sort of the backbone
of those products and initiatives.
And then today I am joined
by Eric from Salesforce
who's a director of
technology sustainability
and Rao from Adobe,
who's in senior program
manager for Cloud FinOps.
Thanks both for joining
me today to talk about
how you've leveraged CCFT
to meet some of your goals.
So we're gonna get right in.
Our agenda is pretty streamlined.
First, we're gonna talk
about AWS sustainability,
what are some of the goals that we have,
and then, of course, how you
actually can get insights
and visibility into some of those goals
through the customer
carbon footprint tool,
which is available in in
the AWS billing console.
Then I'll turn it over to Eric
to talk about Salesforce
sustainability goals,
what they're doing, and then, of course,
how we've partnered on some
of those sustainability objectives
and some of the reporting
and insights that we
provide to enable them.
And then we will then pass it off to Rao
to talk about a similar set
of in initiatives in Adobe
and how they're driving these
initiatives together with us.
And then what we have a few targeted Q&A.
I've had some, some conversations
while I've been here
in the short time in re:Invent.
And we kind of curated a few questions
that we're gonna talk about, which are,
you know, some topic
areas around generative AI
and sustainability
and so we'll end with that.
And so that's our session for today,
so we're gonna dive right in.
So AWS has sustainability
at the core of a lot
of our operations and
how we provide services
to you and to our builders and partners.
We are a Climate Pledge signatory,
which is Amazon's Pan
Amazon Climate Pledge.
This is to be net zero carbon by 2040.
So Amazon co-founded this
together with Global Optimism
and we are one of the
signatories to the climate pledge
and, of course, abide by
that same set of objectives.
But how do we actually
operationalize that at AWS?
We have a few different
pillars that we work towards.
Some of them are carbon free energy,
so how we actually supply
our data centers with power,
what sources of energy we use
to actually power those
across solar, wind, nuclear
achieving, striving to achieve renewable
and carbon free energy goals.
Also operating the most
efficient as we can
in our operations of our data centers.
We also have circularity
at the heart of a lot
of how we build things.
So whether that be looking at
our critical raw materials,
critical rare earth materials,
how we take those back
as well as circularity
initiatives for our components.
So just a quick factoid
that in last year we had
over 23.5 million
components recycle or sold
on the secondary market
since 2023, excuse me.
We also have a water positive objective.
So lemme just build that out.
So we are seeking to be
water positive by 2030,
and we're about 53% of that the way there.
What does water positivity mean?
It actually means that we're
or replacing more water than
we use in our operations
of our data centers.
So these are sort of
like the three pillars
that we are driving towards
in AWS sustainability
and we partner across
in our entire company
to achieve these objectives.
But of course, so what does
this look like at scale?
So we're, you know,
seeking to provide a
sustainable infrastructure
at scale across 120 availability zones,
over 245 countries and territories
as well as over 338 geographic regions.
We've also looked at
some studies that compare
that we actually operate more efficiently,
about 4.1 times more
efficient than on-premise.
So we are actually kind of
providing that efficiency
for our customers that
are coming to the cloud,
but we know we can't do
sustainability in isolation.
So that's why, of
course, today I am joined
by some of our some of our customers
to tell their story as well.
So sustainability is a
shared responsibility.
We, as AWS,
we had just talked about some of our goals
across carbon free energy,
across water positivity.
So we, you know, as the infrastructure
that are providing these cloud services,
we can, you know, support how
we're building our servers
and the components we put
them, how we're cooling them,
where the water's coming from,
how we handle our waste,
what energy we procure.
So we as AWS can control those
and provide those to our customers.
But we also have the customer partnership
where customers like yourself
are leveraging our services.
And so this would be where we need
to actually support our
customers on how they use AWS.
So either that could be
through the services we offer,
that can be through the reporting
and insights they're able to
use to make decision-making.
And so this is something
we call shared responsibility
model for sustainability.
So if you're familiar with
the well architected pillar,
this is one of the fundamentals
of the sustainability pillars
in the well architected.
So you can read a little
bit more about it,
but fundamentally this is
sort of the relationship
that we share between AWS
and our customers as well.
So, you know, with that in mind,
we, as sustainability, really
needed to kind of understand
and meet our customers where
they were at as we were,
you know, understanding what
we were delivering, excuse me,
what goals we're taking,
what kind of transparency,
what kind of visibility they needed
to actually meet some of their
sustainability objectives.
Because, you know, again, not
just the partnership model,
but, of course, our customers
are running directly on AWS
so we are a portion of their footprint.
So how do we start to build
some of that relationship?
You know, it's been a
longer term initiative,
but one of the key initiatives
was launching a carbon
footprint tool in 2022.
So our carbon footprint tool,
and I'll show you a
little bit more later what
that looks like and, of course,
kind of where you can learn
a little bit more about it.
But the customer carbon footprint tool
is actually shows our
customer what portion
of the AWS's emissions they're responsible
based on their usage.
So you log into the billing console,
you're able to see that allocated portion,
and I'll a little bit
about how we built that
and we provide that to our customers.
But what we learned along the way was
we weren't listening close
enough to our customers.
We needed to know really what, you know,
what was blocking them from
making some of their, you know,
progress on their initiatives,
how we could listen better.
And so in 2024, excuse me, I
built that, oh no, excuse me.
We kind of opened up
customer survey to some
of our biggest, our most vocal,
our most sustainability-progressive
customers
to really gather them
together to get feedback.
And so through this
mechanism we're able to say,
"Hey, you know, what
can we be doing better?"
And and a lot of what we
heard in the beginning was,
we need more transparency from AWS.
We know we need to know, you know,
our footprint looks running on AW.
We need to know more visibility
about your operations
and so we've done a couple things
in response to that feedback.
One of which was releasing
our power usage effectiveness ratings
in 2024 across our regions.
And so that actually provides visibility
into how we're actually
using power on-site
in our data centers.
We also released our
water usage effectiveness
earlier this year.
So similar to powers is also looking at
how efficient we are in water
usage in our data centers
to cool things down
and so you're able to look
at that at a regional level.
And then, and in 2025,
along with what we heard was
to kind of level up our
customer carbon footprint tool.
Customers wanted to know how
we calculated those numbers.
Could you tell us the methodology?
Is this third party verified?
So we released a verified methodology
to say this is actually how
we're computing these numbers
and that we've had a third party say
that this is up to speed.
And so we did that earlier this year
along with better functionality
and data exports
so customers could get their
allocated portion more easily.
We also, and sorry for the shorthand,
also released location based emissions,
which is a different type of methodology.
So we have both our
market based emissions,
which accounts for some
of our energy attributes
and other credits that we
use in our total footprint.
and we have the location base,
which is essentially the grid,
and this is our scope to reporting.
And then just recently,
just about a month ago,
we released something
called Scope 3 emissions.
I'll talk more about what
that looks like across scopes,
but was sort of like, it now
rounds out the complete pie
of AWS's footprint.
So we have all Scope 1, Scope 2
and Scope 3 emissions, including the tool
so that our customers can
actually see, you know,
where the sources of
emissions are coming from,
whether that be operation,
whether it be our energy sources
or of course our Scope 3.
So things like our hardware, you know,
that go into our server
racks and et cetera.
And then, you know,
we have a lot more plans
going into this year,
so we kind of hit a measure of success
to have complete verified reporting.
And in 2026,
we're looking to increase
the customer experience
and additional granularity
and keep serving our customers
to enable their sustainability initiatives
and we'll touch a little
bit more on that later.
But, you know, we will continue to hear
from our customers like Adobe,
like Salesforce on what they need
and really be responsive to that.
So I talked about Scope
1, 2, and 3, right.
Some of you may be like,
okay, that's old, old news,
I already know what that means.
Some of you might not know
what those Scopes are.
So I'll just give a quick recap
on what Scopes 1, 2, and 3.
So if we're thinking about
carbon accounting that's similar
to financial accounting, this
is actually how we account
for the emissions that we
generate as a business.
So there's something
called Scope 1 emissions.
This is like our operational emissions.
So things like our, you
know, backup generators
or others that we're
fully responsible for.
There's Scope 2, which is essentially
where we're getting our
energy from the grid
and so the sources of energy
that actually supply our data centers.
And then there's scope 3,
which are basically all the
components, materials, hardware,
cement, everything
that goes into our actual
physical data centers
to actually power all
the compute that services
that we're actually
providing to our customers.
And so just as sort of like
a recap on all of those
that sort of just to
provide that visibility.
So how do we actually compute
the sustainably footprint,
the carbon footprint?
So we have a variety of
different data sources
that come from around our business.
So things like hardware
components and processors,
data center building
materials and equipment
like what I just talked about
all the way down to the cement.
The energy consumption
where the grid source water usage,
all of these different data sources,
we actually take in
from the all over our business
to be able to compute this footprint
and actually provide it
out to our customers.
And so this all feeds into something
what I was talking about, the
customer carbon footprint tool
that we actually built to
supply this to our customers.
So how do we do this?
We go through a couple different steps of,
obviously we have to ingest
millions of data points
from around the customer, or
excuse me, around the companies
to be able to actually
generate that number.
We orchestrate that.
So obviously we have numbers coming in
that are on an hourly cadence, on a daily,
weekly, monthly, right.
So we have different orchestration
of how we pull in
and generate those numbers
and actually tally them all up
into our total full total footprint.
We also, because it's carbon,
we often need to either apply
an emissions impact factor
or we have a team of scientists
that actually model the carbon emissions
of things like our components
that feed into our server racks.
And then, of course, we need
to persistent govern that data
because it is data from
around our entire company,
which feeds into some of our
downstream analysis and acts.
So how we actually plan
and forecast what we're doing
to meet our 2040 objectives
and, of course, how
we're reporting monthly
through the customer
carbon footprint tool.
And so I talked a little bit
about how we kind of progressively
take all these different components down.
This is sort of how we go step-by-step
on breaking down our top down allocation
for carbon emissions.
And so we actually do look
at across all our regions.
We are looking down to the
server racks allocating
to our foundational services,
something like EC2 or S3
and then allocate those out
to our non foundational services.
These are the ones that run
directly on services like EC2,
which are running on hardware
and then essentially we allocate
that out to our customers.
So across all of our AWS
accounts, we actually then do
an allocation model to
say, okay, hey, you know,
Adobe across all of your
accounts, this is the portion
of that your usage is generating
based on AWS's footprint.
So this is a quick screenshot
of the customer carbon footprint tool.
I also quick call out that
we have our product manager,
Marta Fraga here,
who's actually supports the
customer carbon footprint tool.
and we'll be at a demo,
we'll segue it to that later.
But if you can see sort
of like this is sort
of the screenshot you navigate
it to and billing console
and you find the tab
and we can look at both
market-based emissions
and location-based emissions.
And then you have different data exports
in terms of the range that
you can pull for your needs.
This would be actually
our market-based emissions
of a sample account.
Of course, this is nobody
in particular's account,
but you can see sort of the example here.
And then here is our
location based emissions
so this was just sort of an overview
on how we've actually got to the point
where we are now across
all of our sort
of sustainability objectives
and getting down to the CCFT.
So now I just wanna turn it over to Eric
to talk a little bit
about how we partnered
and worked on this.
All right, thanks.
- Thanks, Alexis, this is great.
Appreciate everyone being here.
It's definitely been a journey.
Salesforce has been a
customer of AWS for a while
and, you know, kudos to you guys
for consistently pushing the envelope
and bringing more sophistication
to a very complicated problem.
So thank you everyone who's worked on it.
I'm Eric Gertsman, I lead our
tech sustainability program
at Salesforce.
Want to give you guys
a kinda a big picture
of what we mean when we say
Salesforce sustainability.
I'll talk about four quick pillars
and then we'll dive a little bit deeper
into our infrastructure program.
So, you know, emissions
reductions probably one
of the biggest first starting
points that we focus on.
We wanna be net zero by 2040 as well.
And that's, you know,
looking at long-term
Scope 1 and 2 targets,
total carbon as well
as our carbon intensity
for our Scope 3 targets.
You can see those reflected up there.
To do this,
we have to reduce our value
chain emissions significantly,
that's Scope 1, 2, and 3.
And we want to be more
efficient internally,
the things we have control over
per the shared responsibility model.
But we also, you know,
rely on and work with our
main providers like AWS
to continue pushing the
envelope and decarbonizing.
We have an agent force for
net zero cloud product,
which is essentially a
sustainability management console
and helps our clients, you
know, really track, analyze,
report and reduce their
environmental and social impacts.
So it's something, if you're
in into that industry,
you should take a look.
It's a great way to tally
and and footprint.
And then we have agents, as you know,
Salesforce is big on
agents, as many of you are.
And and there's a lot of internal
and external agents that are doing a lot
of great work with sustainability.
and if we wanna talk about
that near the end, we can.
As far as energy transition goes,
we are pushing hard to continue
moving the industry forward.
For ourselves,
we have been a hundred percent
renewable energy since 2021
and you know,
that is Scope 1 and 2.
We are looking further than that.
We're looking at
location-based grid emissions,
We're looking at, you know,
our Scope 3.
We're trying to, you
know, look at, you know,
as the market is market-based emissions
by time and space and consider
what the right thing is
for the world and the economy.
We're helping to innovate at scale, right,
and scale certain technologies,
whether that's, you know,
efficiency, fuels, renewables, removals,
pushing the industry where we can,
where we don't necessarily
have direct control,
but we have, you know, our influence.
We wanna be nature positive.
Nature positive doesn't always show up
in everyone's sustainability reports,
but it's important to us.
We believe that the health
of business relies on
the health of nature.
It's kind of a no-brainer.
We all float around on this rock together.
However, there has been studies
from the World Economic Forum and others
that say that there's a tremendous
amount of economic value,
in fact, $10 trillion worth
of annual business value
and almost 400 million jobs
that can be developed by 2030
if we implement nature-positive
policies out there.
So huge, huge to think about.
We wanna re reduce our impact.
We've talked a lot about carbon,
but water is a huge focus.
It's a hyper localized resource.
We're thinking about it.
Our data centers and
resilience of the power grids.
Power grids use a lot of water,
something we're very
focused on going forward
and we're also thinking about investing
in up upstream watersheds,
quite literally upstream to make sure
that we have resilient sources of water
to continue powering our
data centers and our offices.
We also have a hundred
million dollars, you know,
nature and sustainability fund.
We are looking at nature-based solutions
for decarbonizing, you know,
through nature solutions
like the 1 trillion Tree Initiative.
Many of you may have
heard of that, 1t.org,
very important initiative.
And then we recognize
that big companies are
not gonna do this alone.
We have to foster an
environment where ecopreneur,
small mission-driven
companies that are doing a lot
of good sustainability
work can be successful.
And, and through our
philanthropy, our ventures work,
putting our full capital
stack at play there
to support them.
So when we talk about our
infrastructure sustainability program,
I'm focused on a few things, you know,
over this year into next
year on that right side,
so all of these stuff, sokeep an ear out
for how data transparency
and data, you know,
feeds into each of these things,
and I'll talk about that a
little more in the next slide.
But, you know, first and foremost,
we're transitioning to public cloud.
We have a lot of our co-location
data centers currently,
but we've rapidly deploying on a AWS
over the last few years
that requires a lot of
data to understand sort
of the right, the right, you
know, economic incentives,
the right sustainability, you know,
impacts, and then going
forward, making the case
for continued deployment.
But to do that,
we also have to rightsize
that utilization.
We don't, we don't wanna just, you know,
willy-nilly just throw all of our capacity
without making sure we're doing it
in the right most
mindful, thought out way.
So we have been
rightsizing our utilization
and getting much more efficient
over the last few quarters
and years, really.
And in this shared sustainability,
excuse me, shared responsibility model,
we have thought a lot about
cost driven optimizations,
you know, FinOps professionals,
if you're in here, it
sounds like there's a few,
you think a lot about, you
know, keeping costs low
and thinking about cost to
serve and, and unit costs.
We do the same thing with a carbon lens
and they're very, very similar pathways
and it's okay to, you know, work together
and one ride the coattail of the other
and oftentimes work together to double
sort of the, the impact and the incentive,
you know, business drivers.
But it's includes things like, you know,
selecting the right instances,
which I think a lot of
you are thinking about,
using S3, intelligent tiering,
upgrading to EBS, you know,
so keep, things like that.
You know, suspending or
releasing ODCR capacity,
things that make you more efficient
and drive costs down and, and carbon down.
We're also kind of taking it a view
of our own infrastructure,
deploying our customers
in a more efficient and and effective way.
So we think about the
efficiency as, you know,
and we try to benchmark where
they should be based on,
where, you know, we seek similar customers
and try to help give them tools to,
to deploy the most effectively,
which then, of course, makes
us more efficient as well.
But we're staying mindful of
regions, regions for, you know,
carbon intensity, but also
water stress, big deal.
And we are giving customers an option
to actually deploy
or migrate either from their co-location
to clean regions
or from, you know, AWS-to-AWS regions
you know, if they have priorities
to be in the greener regions.
We're trying to develop software code
that's more, you know, efficient, elegant,
and avoids anti-patterns
that really can drag
resource utilization down.
So it all starts with that underlying code
and it's both human generated code
and AI generated code
that we're really trying to
think about going forward.
We're tracking water.
We're tracking E-waste.
We're trying to set the
performance expectations.
Try to understand when we're
talking about WE and PUE,
we're thinking about climate.
We're thinking about where, you know,
what is the right strategy,
the trade-offs between carbon and water?
And so data is highly important for that
and then, of course, we're
continuing to engage a variety
of stakeholders, customers,
regulators, investors
and data is super important
for those purposes.
So I wanted to kinda reiterate
some of the things, you know,
different types of data
have different purposes
and you know, we need a lot of it
for a lot of different purposes, right.
So location-based grid
emissions is important
for certain uses, market based we require,
and thank you guys for,
for continuing to push
to bring more types of data to us.
Scope 1, 2, and that supply chain
is really important as we, you know,
become more sophisticated
with the decisions we make
as customers, suppliers, our customers.
It's a big ecosystem,
where we have to all, all
think and work together.
And so that as sort
of dissected by master payer account
and subaccounts by regions,
by service level stuff.
WE, we talked about by region,
but you know, all regions
with, with withdrawals
and potentially in the future a variety
of of other things which
I've kind of put there,
those are kind of in my brain of things
and I know you guys have
been thinking about this too.
So those four categories
to the right are sort of
where we use things like,
so footprinting, right.
We have to keep track of historicals.
We do that internally to track, you know,
where we are and where
we're hitting our goals,
but we also have to do external reporting,
either through our
stakeholder impact report.
We ave to plug in,
you know, the CDP or the 10K
filings, things like that,
that all requires data from the CCFT
and AWS to get that right.
Forecasting and trendsetting.
We take historicals,
think into the future.
We have science-based targets
we have to hit in 2040
and we need to know what trends we're on
and how we're doing with our current
and forecasting going forward.
Internally, it sort of dovetails
with this internal analysis,
but it goes kind of a level deeper.
'cause we think about each
of our business units.
Many of you know Salesforce
is a CRM company,
which obviously it is, but
we have a lot of other arms.
We do marketing and commerce.
We have Slack under our umbrella now
and Tableau, MuleSoft,
a lot of these products
that people know and love,
but do have sort of different
businesses, different metrics.
And as we think about that,
we need AWS data to match
with that to help us find patterns
and kind of opportunities.
And then lastly is, is stakeholders.
We, you know, talk about
engaging customers,
that is hugely important for us.
Our customers are constantly
asking for what their usage
of our cloud is, our products are.
And, of course, we rely
on AWS in many cases
to sort of pass through some of that data.
But also when we set
expectations for suppliers
and we engage our suppliers,
we think about industry benchmarking,
all of that stuff is gonna be required
and we think a lot about how we can bring
that data into the richest way possible.
So with that, I will stop,
I'm gonna turn it over to Rao from Adobe
to talk and then looking forward
some discussion after that.
- [Alexis] Okay.
- Thanks, thank you Alexis.
so for that nice context as well
as the introduction and thanks Eric
for walking through the, you know,
Salesforce sustainability journey.
You know, it's inspiring
to see how this collaboration
drives the collective progress,
you know, in our industry.
So this is a perfect example
of the collaboration.
And, hello, good afternoon,
my name is Rao Chargondla.
I'm a senior program manager at Adobe.
I lead the initiatives in cloud FinOps.
as well as the sustainability.
So one of the things is like
at Adobe, the sustainability
is mindful and intentional.
So that thing that we
wanted to kind of do is
that the sustainability
is not a kind of journey.
It's not a just it's not a destination.
So it is actually
ingrained as a business DNA
within Adobe.
One of the things that I
wanted to focus on here
is that Adobe Sustainability journey
stands on three pillars.
So one is the product pillar,
and the product pillar
is where we are developing
the digital workflows
for our customers
to enable their process flows
and the second one is that
operational sustainability.
In the operational sustainability,
we are enabling our internal as well
as external operations and efficiencies.
And the third one is that we collaborate,
which is the advocacy.
We collaborate with our
partners, with our customers
so that it, we are actually going together
as one partner model.
And to enable this strategy,
we have all actually developed
the five guiding principles.
One is empower our customers
through our products.
You all probably aware Adobe Acrobat,
I'm sure most of you
are using Adobe Acrobat.
Adobe Acrobat, Adobe document Cloud
through which we enable digital workflows
and through which we
save billions of papers,
which is, you know, printing
and also Adobe sign
through which we are enabling
the digital signatures
whereby, you know, reducing
the logistical carbon.
So second one is
that building the sustainable
innovative workspaces
for our employees.
So our facilities are 80%
of them are lead certified.
So what that means is that it, you know,
one of our recent buildings
at Adobe Head headquarters,
which has onsite renewable energy
as well as our own water
circulation system,
which reduces the load on municipality.
So the third area is the boosting
of productivity within
our own data centers
for the Scope 1, Scope 2 emissions
whereby reducing the PUE
and also kind of cutting
down the under emissions.
The fourth area is that
employee engagement.
So we have a number of green teams
and they engage thousands
of our own employees
who actually kind of do
90% of our waste recycling
that happens as part of the
green teams and the effort.
The last one is what we
call it as a transparency.
So bringing the transparency that is
through annual sustainability reports.
The annual sustainability report,
which not only kind of provides
all the en environmental parameters,
but also brings the
what is the ethical AI,
ethical and sustainable AI?
And as well as the data transparency
into the, you know, mix of it.
So there are the five guiding principles
that drives our overall strategy.
So obviously it is not just,
you know, Adobe,
but I think it's a
partnership with our partners
as well as the customers.
Now when it comes to our commitments,
so we have our North Star,
North Star is to become net zero by 2050.
So, which is kind of very similar to most
of your organizations.
So however, so these, the
milestones that you see here,
the commitments that you see here,
they're not just aspirations,
but they are milestones to our progress.
So two of the important milestones
which you can see here is
that our operations,
which is Scope 1, Scope 2,
reducing our emissions by 42% by 2030.
And the second one target is
our supply chain,
reducing that the emissions by 52%,
which is where our cloud as
well as our supply chain,
they sit in this category.
And apart from that,
so we have four of the different
operational milestones,
a hundred percent renewable energy,
electricity by 2025.
And then 90% of our waste
has global waste recycling diversion.
And again, 80% of our buildings
continue to maintain
the lead certification.
And then 25% is, you know,
reduce the water
consumption goal, you know,
both within our own data center as well
as kind of overall per employee.
So driving sustainability is not
as a kind of, it's a
shared responsibility.
Obviously, you know,
the partnership is a
very important aspect.
So there are three things
that to keep in mind.
One is data, right,
So from data
and deriving the insights,
that's one important aspect.
Second one is that reporting aspect
from data to reporting.
So we have several
types of reports, right,
so sustainability disclosures
and, you know, deep diving
the internal reports
to understand the carbon
footprint for each
of the products.
And the third thing is that
how we are actually kind of going to get
that programmatic data access
from the CCFT standpoint.
So our partnership with AWS is
that our inventory Adobe inventory
is standards aligned
as well as we are greenhouse
gas protocol enabled.
But where the CCFT data adds value is
that it enhancing the data so that,
I mean we do our own data
in the form of spend based estimates.
So to bring the precision together.
So that is where the Scope 3 data
that plays an important role here.
So again, in summary,
so, again, sustainability
is a shared responsibility
and a shared progress that we are making.
Thank you for all the, you
know, support from the AWS
and of that, you know,
we were kind of bringing
that information together.
Again, let's make every pixel
and every partnership count, thank you.
- Awesome, thank you.
(audience clapping)
Awesome, thank you,
Actually the funny story is last year Rao
and one of his colleagues Tridar said
that this year we wanted to
be on stage talking about
how we deliver Scope 3,
and so we actually came full circle moment
that we are here on stage presenting that.
So we just have a few, a little
bit more to wrap up here.
So obviously as you saw the headline
of our talk collaboration is key, right,
and sustainability.
We can't do this in isolation
sitting up here with two
of our customers, right,
and telling us how we need to
kind of meet our commitments
and our goals and drive transparency,
but also, you know,
their part in, you know,
driving their sustainability initiatives
and the demand things
that there are things
that you can do like running
well architected pillar reviews
that have a sustainability dimension.
So you can work with account managers
and any of our technical
field community to do
those type of sessions.
But, of course, you know,
like I started to talk today
and I saw that only three
of you have seen the CCFT.
So that means by the
end of this conference,
I want all of you guys have seen the CCFT.
So please go see Marta
and some of our good friends over
in the showcase at the Venetian we have.
There's a very large sign
that to sustainability.
There's a bunch of cool demos.
Please go and you know, check it out.
It will be worth your time, I promise.
And then a shameless plug as
I'm doing another talk tomorrow
where we actually talk about
how we built some of our
core data infrastructure
using AWS Native Services.
So please also join me for that
if you wanna see a little
bit more of the guts of like
how we built this using
some of our core data
and AI services
that actually feed this
into the customer carbon footprint tool,
which you can do.
With a few minutes left,
I had kind of heard some
conversations in these early days
about maybe some topics
we just wanna, you know,
we got about nine minutes left
to just kind of bring some of these,
some questions and topics I've heard.
And so did wanna kind of
ask you guys a few questions
while we're still here together
and I think the elephant in the room
that I've heard from some
folks is GenAI, right,
and so we obviously we're here
as sustainability professionals,
but wanted to get your take
a little bit on like how,
you know, as large
organizations like Adobe
and Salesforce are starting
to kind of grapple with,
you know, being, you know,
in a sustainability position,
but also with the growth of AI
and we know there are more
environmental pressures with that.
So maybe I just ask, you know, Eric,
if you wanna like comment or sorry Rao.
- Sure, I can start.
I think couple of four things is that,
I mean, gene AI is a
really a force multiplier,
certainly it has a double edge.
One, is that kind of a positive
from the opportunities standpoint.
There are couple of opportunities,
several opportunities.
One is to kind of how we can bring
that unstructured data together
and then to kind of from
data to insights, you know,
that is just certainly is a feasible
from the sustainability data standpoint
and also to bring that to
all the way to the, you know,
ESG disclosures that we publish.
So that's something that we
do and that is been happening.
But where on the other side,
which is the challenges
front is obviously kind of,
you know, we all know there
are a couple of things
that are adding up.
One is that, you know,
the more you bring in,
the GPUs, then you know,
you are adding more energy
and you water consumption.
So, which like for an
organization like Adobe,
you know, carbon footprint
is growing, right,
and the other area is that, you know,
you are refreshing that
GPUs so frequently,
there is a E-waste that is happening,
unless you are kind of
extending the life of that,
you know, GPUs within that.
So I think
because you know, the,
when you are looking at
that accounting part of it,
right, so you are accounting
that to the customers as well
from the, you know,
hyperscalers to customers.
So that this is where the opportunities,
there are opportunities,
there are challenges,
but I think it also kind
of depends on like when we
look at the finally like ROI
versus the cost, right.
So we are kind of, you know,
I mean, I know sustainability
is one of the pillars
for the well architected framework,
but what we, or what we
were trying to do is that
to in introduce the sustainability
as part of the region selection process.
So that's something is, you know,
definitely is helpful from that.
- Great.
- Yeah, I mean,
obviously we are looking
a lot of scary things
in the future that may come from AI,
but I'm fairly bullish on it.
I think that AI
is actually gonna help
sustainability quite a bit.
Yes, we have to be mindful of
our data center energy usage
and we will, but I honestly
think that AI has an opportunity
to transform these
infrastructure systems, right.
What you're talking about
data centers, you know,
being able to, to do better
intelligent automation,
really allows you to save costs
and be more reliable, be more efficient,
and even upstream from that,
like the, the power grids, right.
There's a tremendous amount
of opportunity, I think
to forecast, you know, supply and demand
with around time and space to get more,
you know, benefits there
and, you know, in
integrate more renewables
to the grid, things like that.
So I'm excited and also it's
gonna accelerate innovation.
The IEA, I think said that 50%
of the carbon reduction
we're gonna see in 2050
will come from technologies
not even invented yet,
which means that we gotta
get these technologies online
and the faster we can do that, the better
and AI, I think it's really
gonna push that forward
quite a bit.
And I think just modeling,
I think AI does this really great.
We just take so much data
and help us model things, you know,
and when we think about mitigation,
whether it's like near term
stuff around like, you know,
flood risk or sea ice
change, things like that,
or you know, longer
term things like drought
or, you know, tree canopy, you know,
growth and water retention,
those are important.
And then even policies,
like how certain programs
will change behaviors
like, you know,
carbon pricing, things like that.
AI can help generate models
around what's gonna be the most impactful
and help our policy
makers and our businesses
and other organizations do better.
So it's just an exciting time.
I think just like for
the rest of the world
and industry, there's all opportunities,
but I think sustainability
really needs to leverage AI
as much as possible,
and I think the whole industry
would be better for it.
- Yeah, awesome, great comments.
I mean, I will also say that, you know,
we, as a engineering
manager myself, right,
we have our developers
building products at a faster
pace than ever before,
leveraging some of our core,
you know, developer products like Kiro.
And then, of course, you know,
tomorrow I'll talk a
little about like bedrock,
where we're actually using that
to make insights
and actionability more accessible
to all of our internal and
eventually external as well.
So we're seeing, you know,
obviously some of the kind
of daunting things that
we need to continue
to operate more efficiently,
but then also how we're building
and supplying more
sustainably transparency
and progress leveraging AI.
So we're also seeing that
here with AWS as well.
So I wanted to ask just,
you know, one more question.
We and maybe we'll have
time for the third one,
but we obviously talked about
our journey this year, right,
and, you know, kind of where
we thought we were last year.
We were like, we're never gonna get there.
But we got here and we're,
we're on this stage saying,
you know, we've kind of
reached this, this moment.
Do you think we're done?
Have we like checked the box?
Are we ready to go home now?
Or what else, you know, are Adobe
and Salesforce like needing
from AWS in this space?
Can you talk a little bit
about like how, you know,
some of the initiatives you're driving
and how we're gonna
continue to collaborate? ,
- Yeah, I mean, I kind of
a loaded question, right,
we're never gonna be done.
I think as sustainability professionals
we have to keep pushing the envelope.
And again, tremendous amount of progress.
It's not mission complete
quite yet for any of us,
but I do want to reiterate
that customers really do care
and I think the world cares.
I know we're in a time right now
of very interesting political wind
and I think it's a time
for business to lead,
like show leadership and
be true to your values.
The pendulums will continue
swinging constantly
from the next a hundred, 200, 500 years.
So, you know, I think the, the
importance of sustainability,
it's not just about hugging some trees,
it's really truly about
delivering social value,
economic value, business value,
longevity of your business,
de-risking, you know,
improving a variety of different things
that are associated with your business,
driving down costs, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So for us, excuse me, it is not done.
Thank you for your partnership.
We want you to keep going.
I think the things we would
like to see is, you know,
just continued accessibility,
more access to our data
and maybe even better tools,
maybe easier, you know, APIs,
more recent data, right.
Like no, you know, low neo lag time,
which I know is on the horizon,
which is exciting.
Granularity of data, right,
you know, we sometimes
look at very high levels,
but going forward, we're
gonna go deeper and deeper
and deeper and our stack
and try to understand where
the carbon footprint's coming
so we can analyze that at a better level
to help us, you know,
make better decisions in
our sustainability program.
And I think probably,
you know, actionability
or identifying opportunities
within our deployments
on AWS is an area where we'd
love your support more and more
and more and help us understand the places
and that shared responsibility model.
I know there was a very
clear pink and blue category,
but the reality is, you know,
you know so much about
your infrastructure.
You know so much about running,
you know, workloads on the cloud
that the more you can help
your customers figure out
ways to be more efficient,
I think would be great.
So these are things
we could talk about next year, right,
and the year after and the year after.
- We'll, stay busy, yes.
- Yeah, I could just say ditto,
but one of the things though,
certainly more and more
for customers are asking
about, you know, what's the
carbon footprint for your,
you know, product X.
We are not there yet.
I think we at this point of
time to kind of trying to
bring that together to be able to dissect
and then allocate it to the product level.
It takes a little bit
of more for the effort.
So that's one use case.
And the other one is
that, you know, again,
mostly the customers from the Europe,
they started asking the
questions about, you know,
yeah, GenAI footprint and
I think, you know, again,
that all points
to that what Eric you
were mentioning about
the data granularity and
the data accessibility.
I think those are the top items
on our agenda as well.
And then we are actually kind of excited
about the console, CCFT console
because of that, that gives
them more access also kind of
from that standpoint.
And, of course, one of the exciting things
that you were mentioning
about in the roadmap is,
you know, monthly data,
availability of monthly data.
So, yeah, no, I mean I think
for the last 12 months or so,
I think there's a tremendous progress
that's been made, but certainly, you know,
continue to push the for data
accessibility and granularity.
- That's awesome,
I mean, I always like to hear
that there's gonna be plenty
of work for my engineers
for a while to come.
So sounds like we got
a lot of things coming.
So we have a lot of things planned
and as I look over at
Marta who will be one
of the key orchestrators in 2026,
so keep watching this place.
Lots of interesting things in terms of
where we're driving granularity so
that partners like yourselves, like Adobe,
like Salesforce can continue
to kind of innovate on AWS
with sustainability in mind.
So really thankful for
you guys joining today.
Like I said, just one
more like shameless plug,
go to our demo desk in the
showcase, big sustainably sign.
Would love to see your
faces again tomorrow
at the other session
where we're actually
gonna do a chalk talk,
building out sort of the infrastructure,
how we built some of the underlying,
I like to call it guts of the CCFT.
So would definitely be happy
to see you there as well.
Also, please rate our session
five out of five stars.
We are, you know,
sustainability is still
fundamental, right,
it's still super important.
So wanna keep bringing back these insights
and bringing back these
perspectives for you.
So really appreciate your time today.
Don't forget AWS Skills Builder.
Here's my obligated slide
that I need to pop up for you,
but will also,
I kind of did sort of a
pre-curated set of questions,
but we'll be around
for a few minutes if you wanna
come up and chat to us after.
So thank you again so much.
(audience clapping)